[Music]
this beetle is going into the city to
see his lover she's a dancer but this
1912 film is not just a staggeringly
weird tale of insect infidelity it's the
true kickoff to a stop-motion tradition
that has given us a ton of wildly
different movies but this invention
didn't come from Hollywood it was made
by an obsessive collector in Lithuania
who wanted to see insects dance
stop-motion is this combination of
simplicity and very very tedious work an
animator arranges objects in poses and
takes a picture you move the object
slightly and take another picture played
successively it looks like motion you
can tweak the process in a lot of ways
adding more frames and more precise
movements will make for a smoother
animation the potential of this illusion
of movement was obvious really quickly
like in 1908 the sculptors nightmare
where busts briefly moved or a dream of
Toyland likely from the same year which
made toys come alive but it took a
European collector to elevate it to an
art form that changed the movies
[Music]
Vladislav star veg was born in Moscow
and bounced around the pre-revolution
Russian Empire ending up in CONUS a city
in modern-day Lithuania then called
Kovner some sources say star wysz was a
Natural History Museum director there
others say he just had a huge insect
collection either way he had a problem
as he revealed later he was commissioned
to make educational films to show the
life of stag beetles
he waited days and days to shoot a
battle between two beetles but they
would not fight with the lights shining
on them so he started experimenting with
making stationary insects looked like
they were moving
he started with that stag beetle which
he called by its scientific name Luke
Anna's service the goal was to show its
fighting behavior but his next insect
movie left two fiction to tell the tale
of Helen of Troy in 1912 the camera
man's revenge that insect infidelity
movie became his most influential early
work see how the artist is actually
painting another beetle or how this
grasshopper filming mr. beetles affair
with a dragonfly
look how his tripod has individual legs
these miniscule touches were everywhere
he said he did it by installing wheels
and strings in each insect and
occasionally replacing their legs with
plastic or metal ones he used black
threads to help move them and it worked
[Music]
after the Russian Revolution starfish
fled to Paris he continued making films
by the time he made frog land he changed
his name from vladislav to Ladislas to
make it easier to pronounce in French he
continued to make incredibly influential
art with stop-motion because
actors always want to have their own way
he had a host of popular films and
stop-motion quickly influenced popular
art and special effects starfishes
stop-motion inspired the work that was
done in king kong terry gilliam
the director and animator behind the
surreal Monty Python stop-motion
animations said star veges the mascot
was one of the best animated films of
all time in Star Vij's masterpiece the
Roman do Renard clearly inspired wes
anderson's the fantastic mr. Fox this
combination of wild invention and
obsessive detail created a new art form
at the end of the camera man's revenge
the grasshopper screens the movie he
filmed through a keyhole the one of mr.
beetle cheating on his wife she hits him
with an umbrella the movies changed
forever
The Beatles spent the night in jail
[Music]
that's it for this one in this series
about big changes to movies that came
from outside Hollywood stop-motion is a
really global form so I want to know
some of your favorite examples in the
comments I also want to leave you with a
testimony to starve itches work which is
that in some of the early reviews people
were very very impressed with how well
he had trained his beetles to move
around and I honestly don't know if they
were joking